Down on Wall Street,...
...Google overtook Apple as the most valuable company in the world...
...by market capitalization on Tuesday...
...after a strong holiday quarter earnings report...
...that drove its stock price up 5% overnight.
When the stock market opened on Tuesday,...
...Google had a market value of 550.6 billion,...
...beating out Apple's market cap of 529.1 billion...
...for the first time in its history.
The rankings represent more than just a constantly fluctuating vanity leader board...
...though it is certainly that as well.
It is the combination of the slow sea change in thinking...
...about which technology giant is best poised to grow...
...in the second half of this decade and beyond.